-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
And this is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
And now let's get to the news.
The Biden administration
is set to announce
that Americans should receive
a coronavirus booster shot
eight months after
being fully vaccinated.
So, if you got your second shot
in March,
you'd have to get your booster
right around the time
we re-invade Afghanistan.
Former President Trump
appeared last night
on Sean Hannity's show.
Yeah, no kidding.
At this point,
it's as newsworthy
as Sean Hannity appeared
on "Sean Hannity."
I'm surprised
he's not organizing
the office softball league.
It was announced yesterday
that Texas Governor Greg Abbott
had tested positive
for a breakthrough case
of the coronavirus.
Now, I would never wish ill
on the governor,
but since he never wore a mask,
I don't have to.
United Airlines reportedly sent
a memo to flight attendants
that asked them
to avoid using duct tape
as a measure to restrain
unruly passengers.
And so did Spirit Airlines,
saying,
"Stop wasting it.
We need it to fix the wings."
The Washington Football Team
has reportedly
narrowed down the options for
new names down to three choices.
Oh, my God, who cares
what it's called?
Buffalo's football team
is the Bills,
and Buffalo Bill
was born in Denver.
Nothing matters.
Call it anything.
Go down to the zoo
and pick an animal or something.
Hey, otters are cute.
Washington Otters -- done.
I can't believe we're going to
be out of Afghanistan
before you pick a team name
to miss the playoffs with.
Health officials in Los Angeles
announced yesterday
that masks must be worn
at large outdoor events
that attract over 10,000 people,
or, as it's known in L.A.,
an exit.
And finally, Drake recently
revealed in an Instagram comment
that he had the coronavirus and
said it had caused hair loss.
Said Drake, "It started from
the bottom, now it's here."
[ Light laughter ]
What was that?
Oh, the monologue.